hey guys and welcome to another 1-hour
money-making challenge to date we're
going to be focusing on seeds what we're
gonna be doing with the seeds is
planting them watering them and growing
them into saplings because often times
there can be extremely good margins on
these seeds most notably right now is
the palm tree see actually I think I
just bought one we bought the seeds 41
to 65 and it looks like it's selling for
50k right now so that is a nine-game
margin which is just ridiculous we also
bought you seeds papaya tree seeds and
maple and musi so if you're doing this
rather efficiently you can do about 1700
seeds per hour however we only have
bought maybe 1,300 so far and I think
that'll be more reasonable to get done
while making a video but you can't
expect to even do more of these per hour
alright guys so I'm gonna go ahead and
claim all the offers and transfer the
seeds over and double get ready alright
so before I get started all I'm gonna do
is add up how much money I have so far
spent on the seeds just so I have a
baseline to work with here so on my
other account I put the offers in for
the exact same price except for the palm
tree seeds which I put in for an extra
1.5 K on the other account so we'll just
keep that in mind so let's go ahead and
claim all the items here and we'll go
ahead and cancel all the offers so the
one I want to do first is definitely
palm tree see just because the margins
on the right now is so ridiculous okay
so start off here we have palm tree
seeds that on average rabat at about
forty seven fifty each next up we have
you seeds which we bought at sixty seven
three nine nine times three hundred and
ninety nine of them papaya seeds we
bought at fifty six and ninety across
both accounts and we also bought three
hundred ninety nine of them minus the
price check unfortunately willow tree
seeds we did buy at seventy nine four
six on both accounts and we got just
under hundreds of them and maple seeds
we got at forty two 101 and we got one
hundred and sixty four maple seeds okay
so all in all I spent just over fifty
mil on all the supplies so keep that in
mind for how much money you may require
to do this it is quite a bit however if
you took out the u seeds it would be
half this amount and if you took out all
the palm tree seeds as well as only be a
couple mil per flip pretty much alright
guys so let's get started we're gonna
start the timer at one hour I don't
think it's gonna take this long but who
knows and let's go so if you don't know
how to do this I will explain
the start of here you need a gardening
trowel easy to get you're gonna want to
put your seeds in the bottom right
corner as well as you will need a bunch
of filled plant pot now you can buy
these on the ground exchange however
their limit is only 600 so you will have
to wait sometimes or you can go buy them
from a gardening shop but they're a
little bit more out of the way that way
to realize I actually need a garden pie
for this one but what you need to do is
go from the bottom right corner and then
across like this you kind of go from pot
to seed from seed to pot pot the seed
see the pot you can kind of see if you
just double-click on every one of them
you're gonna be increasing how many
seeds you can plant per second actually
and it's actually quite a bit easier in
really less click intensive honestly and
once you're done you just Bank it really
doesn't take too long to do all these
like we'll go we'll have a while I have
the time we're almost the only takes to
actually do this one so one of the main
drawbacks here is you aren't getting any
experience but really that's not that
big a deal because currently the margins
days we're gonna be getting 7k every
click here so that is quite a bit of
money per hour I'm not even sure what it
is but by doing all 400 of these palm
tree seeds we are looking at potentially
making close to 2.8 Millis that is
pretty exciting now if you're wondering
why I'm using a garden pie it's actually
because my farming level is only 67 and
you need 68 to plant the seeds and
that's something that I haven't actually
touched on yet I do actually need
farming levels to do this now really 68
is a pretty solid farming level to have
because the only you see to really
missing out on is the magic seed which
is profitable to be honest however what
is it for the magic seed in 75 farming
so I don't know it could be worth
getting and I probably will get it
eventually just actually mainly just for
this process okay so we're just
finishing up the rest of the palm tree
seeds now it looks like it took us about
six minutes maybe a little bit more but
we were talking for a little bit of that
so normally share if that counts and oh
my god it took one more pot last season
there there we are so we've done 400
palm tree seeds now the next step here
is watering them and that is a very easy
if you have luminaire diplomacy and
dream mentor done if you don't it is bit
more of a pain so if you have a dream
mentor done you can water the entire
inventory with humidify spell all in one
inventory I'm just wearing these team
battles
and you just need one astral room
forecast so it's very cheap and it's
like 10 times quicker the alternative is
using a watering can on all of them
which is quite annoying however it does
work and you still make a good GP per
hour profit it's just a bit slower okay
and this should be our last cast so
there we go we did all 400 of them in
probably a minute or minute and a half
maybe so you notice that once you have
watered them they become Pomfrey
saplings watered you do have to wait
about five minutes for them to turn into
regular palm saplings however that's not
usually an issue so if we're doing an
hour of this you will really only have
to wait an extra five minutes at the end
because every time you make them into
watered they'll turn into them on their
own you do have to really pay attention
to it so yeah we're gonna continue on
with the next two seed so we'll do maybe
with you seeds next and once these have
become the saplings we'll toss them into
the ground change quickly because these
guys are getting us the best margins I
want to start them selling okay we're
just finished up to you seats here and
there we go and that probably took only
seven minutes or something like that now
all of our palm tree seeds have been
converted into palm saplings that's nice
so now we'll go ahead and check the
margin so hopefully it hasn't decreased
too much but I think we should be good
because we actually bought the seeds
very cheap more so than the palm tree
saplings being very expensive yeah
there's still 48 400 which is excellent
we'll go off and sell those for 4870 48
303 nine seven is what we're selling and
looks good we'll start those to sell and
then continue on with the process okay
so next up we're just going to be
watering the the ucs which you only take
a minute roughly then we're gonna move
on to I guess maybe the papaya seedlings
and that will be pretty much it then we
just have a little bit of stragglers to
do now that I'm in the process of doing
this I think this might be quicker than
I originally thought I had the number 17
hundred per hour from the last time I
did it so maybe I didn't have the
humidified spell then I don't know
because it seemed pretty quick we're
only 20 minutes in plus I'm talking plus
I'm recording a video and just checking
on things so I'm not doing this the most
optimally possible either gave it
finished up do use saplings already
that's nice and quick all 400 of them
have been watered and if we have a look
at the grand exchange the saplings
selling reasonably quickly in a minute
we pretty much sold 14 already see you
next up we'll do papaya tree seeds and
then we only have like what 200 more to
do it's very quick all of the UCS have
turned into u saplings and we have
stopped selling these things so well so
we bought the youth seeds for sixty
seven three nine nine and we're gonna
sell them for sixty eight seven nine
nine so that is just over one point five
K in profit which is still pretty nice
sixty-eight seven fifty confirm so
that's a one point three cane profit
times four hundred is well five hundred
forty K nothing to be ashamed about
there okay and there we go that's gonna
be it for the paya seeds and now we just
have to water these guys okay and there
we go we've watered all of the Pius a
Plains so that's pretty much the bulk of
our seeds that's twelve hundred of the
like thirteen fifty or something that we
got so all we have left to do is 164
maple seeds and ninety nine abilities
which will proceed I had to do a
relatively quickly here okay there we go
we just finished up the maple seeds nice
and quick there and the last thing we
have to do is willow seeds we have just
ninety nine of okay there we go we've
added all the seeds to the pots that's
the most time-consuming process there
last up for sure this time is just
watering the last bit of the plants and
that's everything done and we'll
probably have it all done in forty
minutes so maybe this is closer to about
1700 seeds per hour but I'm sure you
could do it quicker man I love this
humidifier spell when I first got it I
thought I'm just gonna use it for a
commute affiant clay which is completely
awful I would not recommend doing that
but this this is super handy and there
we go guys that is all of our seeds
watered and potted and everything is
good to go so we just have to wait about
five minutes for these guys to
completely turn into the sapling and
we'll work on putting the papaya sapling
and for sale now so the palm tree
saplings are selling relatively quickly
we've sold 80 of them so far you see
it's not so much we've only sold one so
far so off to keep an eye on that maybe
change the price a bit later because the
papaya sapling we're selling for sixty
three nine eight and to be buy that for
56 and ninety that's been eight hundred
GP profit on those which is pretty good
considering how cheap does item is
relatively compared to the other one so
63 nineties what will sell them for so
we're going exactly seven
energy P in profit per seed so that's
about 280 K off of the pious a Plains
not bad okay in the last of the saplings
have turned that sounds like I'm talking
about zombie or something but get the
witless a Plains and the maple saplings
so we're hopefully gonna sell to a
little sapling 486 30 and we bought the
was us a plane for seventy nine hundred
roughly so we're gonna get only about
seven he came profit off of this one not
a whole lot but not huge deal either and
last up the maple sap lemur can sell for
just under forty four K and we bought
them for just over forty two K pretty
good margins on this maple sapling
however the actual seeds themselves did
take a bit longer to buy so we're
getting that 1900 to be profit on each
one we only got a hundred sixty five
seeds but that's still three and
thirteen came profit off of those ones
alone and that's a guy so it took us
pretty much forty minutes on the dot
now that's considering the fact that I
was stopping explaining stuff I'm
looking at my bank for stuff like I
wasn't doing this very efficiently
either and were able to do about
fourteen hundred seeds in about 40
minutes so yeah we'll go ahead and wait
for everything to sell off and then
we'll see how much profit we made in
total all right guys this is the
following morning and we did manage to
sell everything off normally this
wouldn't be such an issue but with the
release of Dragon's Lair 2 and its
subsequent buff we are seeing a lot of
seed drops on the table and some of
these things were dropping a little bit
so we did end up losing money on the you
sapling unfortunately which is a bit of
a bummer but in the end we're still
profiting and our total was 56 mil and
100 K pretty well and if we take that
off
our initial buy offers which were 53
mill in 29 K we profited just over three
mil for about 40 minutes work and that
is considering the fact that we lost
probably like five and our K on these
new seeds so you can really see at how
strong a method this can be if you
managed to snap the seeds at a low price
you can make four or five mil an hour
more often you'll make between 1.5 mil
and like 2.5 mill in an hour so keep an
eye out on the praises if you find this
he does really cheap buy it out and turn
it into a sapling and make some Bank
anyway guys I hope you enjoyed the video
if you did don't forget to leave a like
and I will see you next one